[Music]
come on why isn't this working hey you
know we have a new name yeah I know the
merger and everything you rebranded no
no it's like there's a whole new app I
should just I should go I should go wait
hey don't make this harder than it needs
to be don't leave
was I
know it's me baby you have succession uh
yeah man we also have five shows about
being a thousand pounds okay this sucks
this sucks you're obviously a downgrade
this is worse in every aspect I just
want to like watch the shows that I've
been watching I want succession okay
yeah I can do that too oh yeah
how hard is your life
what we have more annoying shows now
yeah
that's it it's just like the branding
thing is super dumb like like you'd
think there'd be something better right
to name yourself yeah well a lot of
things are dumb aren't they
yeah sorry your smart adult drama is
mingling with lowly reality TV okay
sorry also oh I just crashed seriously I
don't feel so good can you enter your
password again